all right so what have we looked at so
far we've introduced the basic idea I've
given you these definitions from a
geometric point of view and also from an
algebraic point of view and then we've
seen how you can use that algebraic
definition to prove some things you know
we can prove why even functions are
called
even functions and the same for odd
functions so now I want us to think
about how to combine these symmetries
because this is where things start to
get really interesting and prickly right
this is a function here which I actually
picked out because a student asked me
about this function and what happens
when you integrate this now this comes
back to the big idea why what I mean
when I say it can be useful to know what
the what the symmetry of a function is
well before I reveal what this
particular function is let me give you
an example of what I mean by useful
right so first I will integrating this
function from memory the question was
asking for something like this and I'm
integrating from negative 2 to 2
now if I were integrating this
particular function then even without
knowing what the function is because I
know it has odd symmetry the left-hand
side is the negative version of the
right-hand side you can see that this
area down here is going to be exactly
the same size where the exactly the same
magnitude as this area on the right hand
side but the difference is it's sign
will be opposite it'll be negative
instead of positive so when I add these
two together because they're the same
size this integral from negative 2 to 2
it'll be zero like I don't even know
what this function is but I still know
that the integral will be zero the
definite integral I should say in a
similar way if I come back to this guy
over here if I wanted you to integrate
again let's her choose a helpful color
here if I wanted to integrate say from I
think the value I chose before was
negative three all the way up to three
okay if I wanted to know what this value
was equal to well again I could
integrate from negative 3 to 3 but I can
take advantage of the symmetry of this
function by saying well hold on a second
this area on the left hand side will be
identical in size and in this case also
in sign
this part of the area over here they're
the same so instead of going from
negative 3 to 3 I could actually go from
0 to 3 and if I just integrate this part
well that was really really fat I didn't
mean it to be that big if I just do this
part over here from 0 to 3 and then
double it I'll get the total area anyway
and generally integrating and having one
of my boundaries be zero is really nice
and convenient because often things
simplify out very very nicely when I'm
substituting in zero so this is the
whole point of it right now this is the
question that we were given and I
instantly wrecked it recognize that as
an odd function even though this was the
actual definition of the function now
the question is how did I know that and
I'm going to illustrate that by telling
you about combining symmetries so let's
start with what happens if you are
adding two functions together if you're
adding two functions together let's
suppose we'll let two functions let's
call them U of X and V of X let's
suppose both of them are odd so if your
two odd functions and if you have some
new function which is made up of adding
those two functions together so you have
X plus V of X what do we know about this
new function over here if we know that
the two components were odd what can we
say about this well let's just test it
out and see what happens if I say what
happens when I put in negative x into
here that's how I can test anything to
do with symmetry well this is going to
give me u of negative x plus V of
negative X just a straight substitution
everywhere I saw X I will put in
negative x but here's the thing
because I know that U and V are odd
that's how I introduced them in the
first place I know some things about you
of negative x and V of negative x if I
go all the way back up to my algebraic
definition this is the part it's
relevant to me here right this
F of negative x is equivalent if my
function is odd to negative f of X these
two things are interchangeable so
therefore with my using my V's down here
there we go I can substitute each of
those once I fix my wonky equals sign
for a negative view of X and a negative
V of X so there's a substitution I can
do because I know that these functions
are odd I can only do that because of
that reason now hold on a second I've
got two negative things here so I can
factor out a minus sign like so that
leaves me with U of X plus V of X inside
the brackets once I've factored out that
negative and when I look at you plus V
that's the function that I started with
up the top here right that is y of X by
definition so I have negative Y of X on
the right hand side on the left hand
side which hasn't changed since I did
the substitution I've got Y of negative
x now what does this mean well this is
the algebraic definition we were having
a look at this means that Y is odd if
you add together two odd functions you
will get another odd function and again
I'll leave it to you to try and prove if
you have two even functions that you
start with or any number like I could
have five or six or seven if you add up
a bunch of even functions you'll get
another even function as a turtle okay
so that's to do with addition what about
with multiplications let's bring this
guy down over here now multiplications a
bit trickier and so before we tackle
this proof let's just think about a
concrete example so if I had again let's
let's call out you and our V here the
two component functions as it were and
let's think about if we were multiplying
two odd functions together like say X
cubed is an odd function and X to the
power of five is also an odd function
what happens when I multiply these two U
of x times V of X what's the result
going to be well in this case just using
my index laws it
x ^ 3 + 5 which is 8 so this new result
the product is an even function because
it's and even index so I'm expecting
here when I multiply two odd functions
together I will get an even function out
well let's just test that out if u and V
are awed and then when I do this Y of X
which is the product of those what
happens when I put in negative x let's
see what happens this is U of negative x
times V of negative X that's just the
straight substitution but then I'm going
to identify just like I did earlier if
these two are odd I can substitute U of
negative x for a negative U of X and in
the same way I can swap this V of
negative x for a negative V of X right
so I've done this substitution because
the functions are but what's going on
here the two negatives are going to
cancel so you can see I just get U of x
times V of X and that's the Y of X that
I started with that's a Y of negative x
on the left hand side Y of X on the
right hand side so this is the algebraic
definition of an even function okay now
the last example I'm going to give to
you before we look at derivatives is
well what happens if I don't have two
odd functions or two even functions I'll
let you prove what happens when you got
one of those what if they are different
so I'm gonna put this guy to one side
over here now I wonder if you can
anticipate this right let's suppose if u
of X is odd like we've been having a
look at and V of X is even okay what is
this going to mean if I multiply these
two together well if I have Y of X being
u times V now I'll do my substitution
see what happens test out the negative
case so he goes Y of negative x equals U
of negative x times V
of negative X I have to be careful
because my you and my V are going to
behave differently since one is odd and
one is even because of this some you
being odd I can swap it out for a
negative U of X but with V of negative X
because V is even by definition it's
just equal to V V of negative X and V of
X are the same because V is even and go
back to my algebraic definition to show
that right so therefore I've got
negative U of x times V of X well this
is very similar if I have a look at this
part here this part here is identical to
the function y of X that I started with
just with a minus sign out the front so
it's minus y of X and then I've got Y of
negative x over here now because
multiplication here is giving us this
sign I can know therefore that Y is odd
when I combined let's go for green this
time an odd and an even function and
just as a bonus because division and
multiplication are related here like
division is just multiplication by a
reciprocal and if you divide an odd
function by an even function or vice
versa you will get the same result
you'll get it being odd and that brings
me back to this guy how did I know that
this would be odd instantly when I
looked at the function well you can see
here on the top here I have a function
which has just on the numerator kind of
symmetry it's been hidden there it's
exit power of 1 that's an odd function
whereas on the denominator let's switch
colors here I know that this is going to
be an even function because it's made up
of an x squared which is an empower and
if you want it to be technically
accurate here you've got X to the power
0 here and 0 actually is also an even
number maybe you've never thought about
where the zero is even or odd but zero
follows all the same rules every other
even number does and you can test that
out so you have an even function on the
denominator this therefore is a
combination between an even and an odd
function by multiplication or division
and therefore the result as you can see
over here on the left hand side is going
to be odd